who are you excited to see tonight such
a good lineup well I mean Shawn Mendes
is playing right now I can see him as
your your twin my twin and I really I
really want to get a photo with them
just to dispel any rumors that I am
Shawn Mendes
you hear that all the time because I was
gonna ask you if you hear those rumors
every day of my life like I'm not every
single day of my life I'm sure he does
too
so we like we'd like to spell those
rumors we're not the same person
although we've never been seen in the
same place at the same time so right now
it's a little suspect that you need to
be pre-recorded have you never met him
do you have it planned out what you're
gonna say when you meet him oh I have no
idea um I would probably just try to
mirror all of this movements but you
guys like oh hey what's up dude I go hey
what's up dad like it's a copy on are
you wish on fan I am yeah I can't sing
in any of his music I don't believe me
but maybe there's nothing on me
[Music]
yeah now I'm even more convinced that
you guys are the same person I think the
music I'll stick to acting
speaking of acting though modern family
has really thrown a lot of shockers at
us this season between the death
Halley's pregnancy what else is in the
pipeline Luke gets pregnant
Luke dies now what else is in the
pipeline you know we always have a lot
of twists and turns so don't expect you
know even though we've already had a lot
already I'm gonna stick that just to be
yet and when they announced that people
were gonna die I thought was gonna be me
obviously that's just me I'm super
insecure as an actor's I called my Aegis
cry was like it's me I know it
and then spoiler alert they killed Dede
who's the gramma on the show but I'm not
convinced that's the only one there's
another death coming long season maybe
that was the mislead I don't think your
character is going to die though there's
no way I think I'm okay I did hear that
Arielle winter said that maybe actually
the show could go to an 11th season what
do you make of that that'd be awesome we
love we love our job we've got I mean
the greatest remember the top comedies
of all time and it's awesome I know we
don't it's cast would love to come back
if we can make it work and will
hopefully keep bringing the funnies or
for all the fans back home yeah are you
looking forward though to sort of doing
something different out of the box away
from the show I mean there's definitely
you know part of it where you've been on
for 10 years so doing another season
it is a lot especially because I started
when I was 10
like I've got life plans I want to go
maybe think about college all kinds of
things so but I wouldn't trade anything
about for another season on the show
right well you did tell us before that
you were actually applying or you got
into USC yeah is that right
so was that still the plan you know I
got accepted to USC and thankfully yeah
that was two years ago
later on they let me defer for two years
so it's coming up on whether or not I
decide if I'm going we'll see
what are you leaning towards we'll see I
you know back
I was like I think it was 17 when I
first started applying like I had
parents of my life being like you need
to go to college now I'm like 20 and I'm
kind of like in that in that thing is in
her life where every twenty-year-old
goes through and like I don't know like
I've been acting for 10 years and I
still don't know what I want to do so
like if you're young and out there and
you know you're getting down on yourself
for not knowing what you want to do like
don't worry I'm a no idea either part of
life right yeah figuring it out
before I let you go I do want to have
you reach into our hand our Santa hat if
you don't mind and pull out a question
who will I be kissing on New Year's Eve
good question that's a good one for you
see after dark Oh Who am I gonna be you
know I'm actually gonna be in Tokyo on
New Year's so I don't know maybe I like
in like the three words of Japanese I
know I can like meet someone fall in
love guess I'm I don't know I'm also
gonna be traveling through Tokyo with my
best friend Shawn Marquette so let's
hope it doesn't get weird after a couple
rounds of sake well you're very charming
so I'm sure if you wanted to find
someone you could help me the Internet
throw out some suggestions
[Music]